Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
Gal Gadot, and James Gunn just announced
that they're working on a totally new
Wonder Woman movie that's going to replace
that original Wonder Woman three
she was going to make earlier this year,
but then totally got canceled
because of all the big DC movies reboot.
means that she will be
one of the Snyder verse
Justice League actors to continue
as their character in the new DC movies.
So we'll break it all down.
And what's going to be different
about this Wonder Woman movie
and why she gets to come back,
but not Henry Cavill as Superman
or Ben Affleck as Batman.
If you're brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos.
There's a bunch of big stuff
coming up Ahsoka episodes.
In a couple of weeks,
I'll be doing videos for everything.
The first big DC series will be Creature
Commandos next year and then the Batman
HBO series about Penguin, but they haven't
announced release dates for those yet.
all new episode videos for everything
that they wind up releasing.
So no worries the big news
this week, though, is that Gal Gadot
just confirmed that she was coming back
to make that new Wonder Woman movie.
We actually learned that she was coming
back months ago,
though, at the beginning of the year,
but a lot of people missed it.
J is going to confirmed it on the sly
just in a regular reply
that got buried on Instagram.
And he does that all the time.
He'll reply to post drop huge information,
big details in offhanded ways
so that it doesn't immediately seem
like he's just given something big away.
most of all,
the new details on Superman legacy
that we've learned
have come from posts like this with him
just answering the questions
or replying or debunking things.
for instance,
he confirmed David Corn Sweat and Rachel
Brosnahan would be the new Superman.
Lois Lane by replying to a tweet
from a trade publication.
He didn't say,
I've cast these people in this movie.
He just said, Oh,
there are some people too.
And that was his way
of confirming the casting news.
So we did the same thing with Gal Gadot
as Wonder Woman months ago.
And now what's changed
is she's just confirmed it herself
with more official comments like,
Oh yeah, I'm definitely coming back.
We're definitely making this movie.
The difference is it is now going to be
canon to the new DC movies and fit
with the backstory of the DC universe
that James Gunn is creating.
last year
he said that some of the Snyder verse
Justice League actors would be recast
and some would continue,
but the ones that did
continue would have their back
stories changed to fit in the new canon.
so all the previous
DC movies are basically elseworlds
now taking place in other universes.
And now she's just another variant
like Loki or the Spider-Verse characters.
you look very similar
to that other version of Wonder Woman,
and those are the movies
we just got done watching
what they're doing
with the Wonder Woman character
just in general
in these upcoming DC movies
is they'll start in the distant past
before she was born
and do the story of the Amazons
from around 5000 years ago,
right before she was born, meaning that
all the gods are still alive and active
in most of the modern superheroes either
aren't around or haven't been born yet.
But for example,
there are lots of ancient characters
in the DC Universe
who are still around in present day.
there was still a Green Lantern that was
active in Earth sector during this period.
Dark side, the forces of apocalypse,
the New Gods, they were all still alive
at this point, Doctor Fate existed,
but it was a different person
wielding the power Vandal Savage
is another big character, too.
James Dean hasn't said anything about him,
but he's another ancient character
who was just around this entire period.
The reason why Patty Jenkins
Wonder Woman three got canceled
last year was apparently whatever
she was doing with the character,
it completely conflicted
with James Gunn's plans for the character
in the wider DC universe.
They haven't released the full plot, but
it would have taken place in present day
had at least some of the other Justice
League characters crossing over.
but given the negative reaction
to Wonder Woman 1984.
I'm totally fine with him
not making that version of Wonder
Woman three
It sounds like it was just going to double
down on the vibe from Wonder Woman 1984
like, Do we need to do Steve Trevor again?
Does she need to be obsessed with her dead
boyfriend again?
The plane going forward right now
is the Paradise Lost episodes
start out the story of the Amazons.
James going to explain it?
Kind of like Game of Thrones on Themyscira
5000 years ago,
and it'll explain the events of why
Zuse created the magical barrier
around the island,
why they cut themselves off from mankind
thousands of years ago, in the events
leading up to the birth of Wonder Woman,
We're doing a television
series called Paradise Lost.
Paradise Lost is a story of Paradise
Island, usually known
as Themyscira,
which is the birthplace of Wonder Woman.
It's almost like Game of Thrones
with Westeros,
but with all of the inhabitants
of Paradise Island.
I'm assuming this means they're
going to recast most of the Amazons
like a new version of Hippolyta
and everyone else except for Wonder Woman.
But if she appeared at all
during this Paradise Lost eras,
it probably just feels like a voiceover
cameo to narrate some of the action
or like a post-credits scene.
Because if she is born during the events
of the series that happened, like right
at the end or the post-credits scene
itself would tease her eventual birth.
James Gunn didn't say when that series
would premiere episode.
Since they haven't done any casting yet,
it'll probably be at least 2025,
not even counting the delays
from the strikes.
the new Wonder Woman movie they're making
would be like the year after that
or later, like 20, 26, 2027,
maybe even later
it also be said in present day in
just like Superman
Legacy has a whole bunch of other DC big
Justice League characters crossing over.
And so would this new Wonder Woman movie.
The newer characters, James
Gunn is introducing.
don't be surprised if David Corn's words
Superman shows up in this new Wonder
Woman movie or the new version of Batman
that they're doing it.
Batman Brave in the Bold.
Right now. Just assuming the strikes
don't delay things more.
The only DC movies coming out of 2025
are Superman Legacy in the Batman too,
with Robert Pattinson.
And that's an Elseworlds movie.
Only Superman legacy is going to be Canon
that year, there is the Blue Beetle movie
that is going to be canon.
The Blue Beetle character will come back,
but they haven't said anything
about doing more blue Beetle movies,
only that he'll show up at some point
during the Booster Gold series.
But it will be the same version.
The character,
all do more videos for that movie as soon
as like a completely separate thing.
that new Batman brave in the bold movie
probably isn't going to be released
until at least 2026 or 2027.
That's the main reason
why they haven't announced two.
The new Batman is going to be
because they won't introduce the character
for a couple of years,
so there's no need to cast them right now.
And he doesn't want to throw water.
On Matt Reeves version of the Batman
with Robert Pattinson.
So they'll probably wait
until after the Batman two comes out
to actually announce who
the new Justice League version of Batman
or the crossover Batman is going to be.
but we might see other bat
family characters
popping up in other people's movies before
Batman braving the Bolt, because we know
that they're going to be full on bat
family in that movie like Nightwing.
Tim Drake, Jason Todd.
They haven't said anything
about a new Canon version of Batgirl yet,
just because of the whole Batgirl debacle
last year.
but they'll probably do her
at some point too.
We know they're doing both Supergirl
and Superman movies at the same time,
so it makes sense
that they're doing Bat Family.
They do some of the female characters
of the team at some point too.
the main reason
why James Gunn is letting Gal Gadot
come back as Wonder Woman
is because his vision for what he wants
his Superman to be is so different
from the vibe of Henry Cavill.
Superman is so much younger
that apparently he just feels like
Henry Cavill would not work
as his new Superman the way that he plans
on using the Superman character.
James Gunn said that Superman legacy
in his new version of Superman is mostly
inspired by all Superman and Christopher
Reeve's Superman and Clark Kent.
On top of that,
one of the big differences from Henry
CAVILL'S Superman will be that way.
More focus on the corn fed
Clark Kent side of his character
as there is on the Superman Kal-El
side of his persona.
In the majority of Henry Cavill,
Superman was focused on him as Superman
like God tier Superman
in very small amounts of Clark Kent.
movie, though,
I do think that Henry Cavill
still could have done
a solid version of Clark Kent.
I think James Gunn wanted an actor
that just felt a little bit more like
Christopher Reeve's Clark Kent in Henry
CAVILL'S Superman and Clark
Kent were kind of like the giga Chad
versions of those characters.
in his new Batman is supposed to be much
younger than Ben Affleck's Batman,
even though I think that he would have
used Ben Affleck again if he could.
Ben Affleck himself
previously told the studio and James Gunn,
probably no more Batman for him.
He basically said he was out.
but the joke about that
and I did a couple of videos about this
a while ago when I was doing flash
movie videos is since he's said
that he's also clowned on himself like Ben
Affleck has clowned on himself
feeling that he finally nailed Batman
during the Flash movie
like it was meant to be his big swan song.
But he finally nailed the character.
You know,
he kind of wants
to come back a little bit,
but he said that in a joking tongue
in cheek kind of way.
And it's my best shit I've done as
I finally figured out how to play the guy.
No, really got it.
I was like, Hold on. Is that I quit.
I know I quit.
And I know I can back it,
but I got it now.
but it was a it was a scene where I got
I get caught, I get saved by Wonder Woman.
Yeah.
During a conflagration with some
some some bad guys.
Saves me with the lasso of truth. Yeah.
And so what happens is that Batman
divulges,
you know, some of his real feelings.
Yeah. About his life and his work.
And it helps you.
It helps you see the character, and now
you want another chance to play it.
And I was like, Wait a minute, I got it.
Am I still with Can I guys?
So really, can we write another story?
Am I I did a video for James Gunn's new
version of the Justice League recently.
He just announced Nathan Fillion is
a version of Guy Gardner, Green Lantern.
And now it seems like his Justice
League will be a lot closer
to the animated version of the team than
the Snyder version of the Justice League.
was a gift from my.
The head of my makeup department
over at Castle.
Her name is Debbie Zeller.
Thank you, Debbie.
I'm looking to the reflection.
Thank you, Debbie, very much for my shirt.
I told you it would come in handy and I
think brings out the green under my eyes.
now he has
played Hal Jordan Green Lantern before,
But that was in the Emerald Dawn
movie Years and years ago after the Ryan
Reynolds Green Lantern happened.
So the funny thing there is
that there had been a fan theory about him
being an awesome manager.
Like he'd be amazing as Green Lantern
going back to his days on Firefly.
Like that's
how long this fan theory gone on.
but then the studio cast Ryan Reynolds.
We know how that went down.
He's been making fun of his time
as Green Lantern for a year
through all the Deadpool movies
And since then, Nathan Fillion has played
multiple DC characters
also in live action for James
Gunn and been in a ton of live action
Marvel movies.
let me know in the comments,
Who do you want to be on this new version
of the Justice League
if it's going to be
a completely different type of team
than the Snyder
versus version of the team?
there's a bunch of stuff coming up.
Ahsoka
episodes will start in a couple of weeks,
so my episode begins for
that will start real soon.
I'm working on a new Fantastic
Four video, new Blue Beetle trailer video.
Be sure to enable alerts from my channel
so you don't miss any of that stuff.
click.
Here for my Loki Season
two trailer video and click here for that
new Green Lantern Justice League teaser.
Thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.